all right the New York Times being
blasted for bias after a leaked
transcript reveals its new plan to go
after President Trump the paper's
executive editor forced to hold a crisis
town-hall meeting last week after
liberal backlash were changing a
headline about recent shootings from
Trump urges unity versus racism to
assailing hate but not guns in the
leaked transcript the editor dean
bouquet is quoted as saying we build our
newsroom to cover one story we did it
truly well but after Russia collusion
fell apart the editor says his paper is
focusing on a new narrative race here's
a quote now we have to regroup and shift
resources and emphasis to take on a
different story so Jessie this
transcript was very revealing but it
also I think solidified a lot of what we
already knew right well it was revealing
in the sense that they admitted that
they were unable to take out Trump
they've admitted that they're not as
influential as they think they are and
they admitted they're not journalists
that their partisan activists because a
real journalist would go back the last
two years and look how did this Russia
hoax actually come into being
but they're spending no time looking
back they've turned a blind eye to it
and they're now just looking at what
else can take out Trump race I don't
believe we'll have the same type of
effect against the president as the
Russia thing did you could see the
ratings for the cables that push that
hopes are not rebounding as they pivot
to race and approval for Donald Trump
among Hispanics and black Americans
since January has actually gone up so
it's also not a very inspiring message
to say that the country is founded on
racism it's a racist nation and we need
to destroy it and Institute socialism in
order to heal it that type of messaging
that this country's racist and the Trump
is racist that all Trump voters are
racists are gonna turn off the very
voters that the Democrats are going to
need to recapture those Rust Belt
districts in order to win back the white
house because race isn't going to work
it's got to be health care education as
Juan said and jobs look like you have
something to say and well I do your
honor and I just want to see I want to
cede my time to mr. waters because I
think he's indicted him self and I just
want more of his testimony rush hour
hopes yes did you miss the entire
a report that said Russia interfered in
the 2016 it was this is what there was
no finding of any collusion no
investigation it was investigation with
two conspiracy and they didn't find a
[Music]
conversation about this move on after
because I said I would see the point to
Jesse because I think he's indicted him
self many years do you think that these
conversations about the activism are
appropriate I think look I just think
you look at the numbers the Pope we had
a poll here at Fox last week it said
two-thirds of Americans think he's
tearing the country apart and that
includes by the way more than sixty
percent of white Americans so something
is going on in terms of the social
fabric and if you're a journalist how
could you not pay attention to it that
to my mind you know what it's like a
this is not a new topic for The Times
The Times been covering I think
yesterday they had a magazine dedicated
to slavery so this is something that
they need to do and I think that what
you hear from Dean bouquet is look we
put a lot of effort into covering Muller
and the conspiracy argument Jesse and I
think they did a pretty good job they
were way ahead of other people saying
that they didn't think that my think
they in fact I think they were ahead I'm
saying
certainly ahead of all those people who
were over at the other channels feeding
the skins breathe in that camp wait the
other channels follow everything that's
written in the time I think they didn't
do it the conspiracy is that they create
they're creating a framework to shape
the news to lay out a blueprint so you
could just slot in all the stories about
race the weather the polls say that they
think Trump is tearing the country apart
is irrelevant because it's the media
that is creating the narrative that
people hear about the fact is the
curtain is now pulled back we see this
and we're we're surprised the rest of
the media smirks because it's been this
way all along the problem so why are
they doing it is because racism is a
quantity where in the media the demand
exceeds the supply so they're gonna have
to keep creating this they're gonna have
to keep doing this and to your point
that's that slave story the slave
article was
probably I didn't read it but I'm
assuming it was probably well well
researched it was probably well done but
I didn't read it but now my assumptions
are this is all part of a greater
narrative to paint Donald Trump is
racist so I'm gonna look at everything
they do as somehow construe artificially
constructed to demonize somebody and
it's not going to stop it's gonna get
worse and we have to admit this country
over time gets less racist do you think
we're more racist now than we were in
the 60s or the 50s or the 1860s it's
getting better but they don't like that
story things are going so well that they
need to demonize everybody so right now
the grey lady is this is bigger than
Watergate grey lady is Nixon and dragged
at this point well you know I think we I
think things are getting better in terms
of race in terms of like if I compare
where my father was to where I am I
don't think there's any question but I
will say this look in there and and your
point there that you agree anybody who
is covered from as a real journalist
knows that he has had trouble with the
race issue all along federal suits about
housing discrimination that birther
movement Mexicans rape I mean just I
could go on Central Park five I wrote a
book about this a year ago that has
nothing to do with somehow oh it's
suddenly discovering we're gonna make
something out this no that's this just
been an issue with truth if you take
each one of those separately they add up
to very little so that's why you have to
list them on the Russia thing a lot of
people the work in news you had invested
a lot of time to read all of their
pieces and it was a lot of time and a
lot of it was always hinting that Trump
was behind it and so I all the podcasts
all the things that they did and I'm
just like what just reporting the news
but I think one things that's happened
is there's this generational change in
the news room so like Dean bouquet I
don't think that he I don't know exactly
what I'm gonna try to put words in his
mouth but there's this generational
change where now I think it's partly
because of the way universities trained
journalists now and that they are
activists and instead of just reporting
the news of like news news organizations
used to be worried that they might make
their advertisers mad you worked in
magazines right they're like oh they're
not gonna like to see that article next
to the picture there's great product
was there worried before now they're
worried about their own reporters and
I'm just for like just report the news
plus bashing the media is now a
bipartisan sport where does Bernie
Sanders like a way to get his base
energized by bashing to me to your point
New York Times is no different than
media matters right right yeah because
they're put they're both pushing an
agenda a political ideological agenda
that's not but I'm glad you said that
Dana
Davis said that the New Times is no
different than the media matters she did
check not true